One of the things that has begun to
worry me is the fact that I'm seeing
change happening at a scale which was
unimaginable before and that is
impacting the industry after industry
after industry.
Every industry I've looked at,
I've seen a trend of major disruption
happening.
Manufacturing is the most obvious does
with robotics and three d printing as of
this year.
It is cheaper to manufacture in the
United States than it is in China.
It is cheaper to manufacture in Europe
than it is in China.
Why is that?
Because of the automated robots that
have two arms that have screens which
show you the emotion with the sensors
they have around them.
I'm talking about Baxter from rethink
robotics or universal.
These robots have become very
sophisticated.
The cost of operation is less than the
cost of human labor,
so we can now have robots working 24
slash seven through the things that
human beings did give it five years.
These robots will become ever more
sophisticated.
They'll be doing many,
many more jobs,
which means that the manufacturing
industry is going to be disrupted in a
very big way.
The good news for America is that it's
coming back here.
The good news for Europe is coming back
there.
The good news for Asia is that it's also
going to become a local industry,
bad news with China because it's no
longer no longer going to happen in
China,
so by the end of the decade,
you're going to see major upheaval in
manufacturing opportunities and problems
move into the next decade.
These men,
these robots will probably go on strike
because we won't need them anymore.
We'll have three d printers now within
15 to 20 years,
we will be able to three d print
electronics.
So imagine being able to design your own
iphone and printed at home.
That is what becomes technically
feasible in the in the 15 to 20 year
timeframe.
So you're talking about major disruption
happening to manufacturing the short
term and then even greater disruption
happening in the longterm.
Now look at finance.
We're seeing the turmoil that bitcoin is
crew guys grading.
You now have many parties supporting it.
Well,
you also have crowdfunding shaking up
the,
uh,
the venture capital industry that they
become less relevant.
We'll soon have a crowdfunding for loans
that,
uh,
in some countries already experimenting
with,
um,
taking out loans by we want to buy a
house.
You want to buy a car,
you simply get it from a large number of
people.
You're now moving into a cardless
transactions for purchasing goods.
We may not need the banks anymore.
We may not need financial institutions
the way we do right now,
so,
so there's gonna be disrupting happy to
financial services,
whether or not financial services we
realized is that in the USA they seem to
be complacent because they've got laws
protecting them,
but the same laws don't apply in other
countries.
We may well have major innovations
happening abroad,
which companies now used to the United
States.
Look at healthcare that already we now
have apple putting a stake in the ground
saying,
we're going to be the platform for
health.
They basically have to have announced
their health platform.
What they want is that all of these new
sensor devices that are becoming common,
which monitor your blood pressure,
which monitor your blood oxygenation.
We Monitor your heartbeats which monitor
your temperature with mighty activity
levels and soon which will monitor your
blood glucose and monitor your
internals.
They want all of these data being
uploaded to the apple platform.
Do you think google,
Google will be left behind?
Do you think Microsoft will be left
behind?
Do you think Samsung will be left
Everyone is jumping into the act,
but soon when you have all of these
data,
we were able to.
We will be able to transform the
healthcare industry because we will be
able to predict when someone is about to
get sick,
we will have ai based physicians.
They can advise us when we're about to
get sick,
that can advise us on what we need to do
to get healthy.
When he said the problem that doctors
have right now is that the data that we
get back from medical tests is so
complicated that they can't.
They can often not understand it,
especially in fields like cancer.
If you look at the reports,
and I've seen some of these reports is
incredibly complex,
add to it,
the genome genomics area,
we're going to be getting the cost of
human genome sequencing has dropped to a
thousand dollars over the last,
uh,
15 years at the rate at which we're
going.
The cost of sequencing will be
practically zero.
So the,
which means they will all have genomes
done.
You combine that with the medical sensor
data combined with the data we have in
the cloud.
You've got a healthcare revolution
revolution.
We won't need doctors for day to day
medical advice anymore would have
robotic surgeons doing sophisticated
surgery.
So we're going to impact the medical
professionals.
We're going to now append the entire
healthcare system.
There will be no it all in the next five
to 10 years.
People don't seem to understand this.
Now.
Look at the energy industry.
We're fighting wars over oil.
We,
five years ago we worried about America
running out of oil.
Today we're talking about Saudi America
because of fracking.
Fracking is a harmful technology.
Nevertheless,
it is allowed America to become energy
independent and soon to become an energy
exporter.
Forget about fracking.
Solar itself is something we've become
negative about,
but solar has dropped about 97 point two
percent over the past 35 years in price
at the rate at which solar is advancing
by the end of this decade,
which is grid parody in the United
States.
Great Parliament is cheaper to produce
energy at home on your soda cells than
buying from the grid.
Move forward another 10 years.
It costs you $100 much to,
to,
uh,
produce your own solar,
your own energy.
Then to buy from the grid,
which means that we have these great
companies now in serious trouble.
This is why you have the utilities
fighting solar,
that they're now started opposing solar
subsidies.
They're now doing everything they can to
stop the solar industry because on its
own solar,
if it keeps advancing the way it will
end and there's every indication that it
will,
it's going to eclipse the fossil fuel
industry.
And solar is one of maybe 100
technologies that are advancing which
will change the energy industry.
So now you have unlimited energy was
guess what?
We have unlimited clean water because we
can simply bond much water as we wanted
them to have unlimited water.
We can now have vertical farms in which
we grow food locally.
Imagine now having 100 percent organic
food where you don't have to have have
insecticides and so on,
pumped into it because you haven't
produced in sealed buildings in,
in,
in vertical farms.
Imagine not being able to three d print
meat so we don't have to start animals.
So we're talking about upending
agriculture and the food production
industry so I can go on and on and on.
Every industry I've looked at,
I've seen major disruption.
Even even a good old communications,
they look at the impact 80 and t,
verizon and sprint will suffer over the
next decade or so.
They've seen the landline business
disappear,
landlines went to a mobile and then now
we have data.
I mean when I travel abroad right now to
make long distance calls anymore because
I just call her a skype.
Imagine when we have wifi everywhere.
Att and t and Google are competing now
to do wire up a regions with super fast
Internet access.
What happens now when you have open
networks everywhere,
so so you can make phone calls over wifi
networks.
We're talking about disrupting the
communications industry.
I can go on and on and on,
but every industry I look at,
I see major disruption happening,
so the world 10 to 15 to 20 years from
now is going to be completely different.
We're going to be disrupting industry
after industry after industry.
The vast majority of companies who are
the leaders right now may not even exist
because the problem is that not only are
people not aware of it,
most industry executives,
they're not invested our money that will
be required for them to reinvent
themselves.
They dare not put themselves out of
business.
So,
so a major disruption as company is
coming.
Our industry heads are worried about
short term performance.
They did not see that this future we're
headed into so they're going to be
disrupted.
We will have new industries coming out
of nowhere eclipsing these,
this old line industries,
nutrilon,
dollar industries,
wiping out existing trillion dollar
industries.
This is the future we're headed into.
For better or for worse.